- The Lion King is out,
and as of this taping,
is having a tricky time feeling
all the love at 60% fresh.
The reviews are still trickling in,
and really could go
either way at this point,
but the trek up this
rock is feeling steeper
than expected, something the last two
Disney live-action films
have also experienced.
Dumbo at 46% rotten, and
Aladdin at 57% rotten.
Could we be facing Disney
live-action fatigue?
Hi everyone, I'm Mark Ellis,
welcome to the After Show.
Yes, I was saying
live-action in air quotes.
So happy to welcome you all
to this particular discussion.
If you have not yet seen the
new Lion King, fair warning,
this is a spoiler-heavy
discussion, so be prepared.
I am so excited to welcome
some A-List members
of the pride here to the chat.
Ladies and gentlemen, she
is a Rotten Tomatoes editor,
Miss Jacqueline Coley's here.
- How y'all doin'?
- Oh, we get applause
today from the crew too.
(chuckling)
- I know.
- And she's Geek Bomb host Maude Garrett.
- Hey y'all, what's up?
- In a very, uh,
seasonal I guess for the
moment for the discussion.
- Why did Maude not get applause?
Let's give Maude some applause.
(applauding)
(giggles)
- Well we saved the best
round of applause for last
because we're in the
presence of greatness,
ladies and gentlemen, Rotten
Tomatoes editor-in-chief,
the one the only, Mr.
Joel Meares is here today!
Oh, this is so exciting
to have all y'all here.
So what we do on this show is we like
to talk about the movie in-depth,
but before we get into that discussion,
I do wanna just pitch it to each panelist
really quick, is this
movie fresh or rotten?
Because I go into this thinkin',
oh well it's Disney, it's The Lion King,
of course it's gonna be fresh.
My opinion is that it's
a very fresh movie,
I enjoyed myself start to finish.
Jacqueline Coley, am I crazy?
- Fresh!
This injustice will not
stand about this movie
not being fresh as far as I'm concerned.
I literally brought out my tinfoil hat
this weekend 'cause
it's a grand conspiracy.
This is a good movie, y'all,
don't let the score fool you.
- All right, Maude, do
you agree with that,
is this a fresh, based on
your shirt I'm gonna say yes.
(singing Lion King theme)
- Yeah, it's fresh as, I
think that not only has
the look of this movie matured,
but so has my take on it.
Because I'm seeing and watching this movie
from a whole different
perspective, of the adult.
That's all I'm tryin' to say.
- Okay, now Joel, you are also
an adult as far as we
know, but you're also
- This is true.
- Is that right?
- the editor-in-chief of Rotten Tomatoes
and we're kinda looking at it right now,
this thing is barely clinging to fresh,
this is like Mufasa on
the edge of the cliff.
- Don't you dare, how dare you.
- And one Scar review could
come along and knock it off.
Do you think this is a fresh movie?
- Fresh-ish (chuckles), yeah, so I think
I understand why the
score is where it's at.
I enjoyed this film for what it is,
I think it's beautiful, there
is a lot to recommend it.
I don't disagree with
anything that's been said
so far, although I'm sure I'll disagree
in a few minutes with
some things that are said.
But I didn't feel anything, and I was left
a little cold by this Lion King.
And I'm not a heartless person,
I will cry at the drop of a hat,
that Subway commercial,
it had me in tears.
But this film didn't quite get
to the Subway level for me.
- You couldn't feel the love tonight?
- I didn't feel the love,
I felt a little lack.
- I'm so happy Maude made that pun for me,
'cause I'm already done with my quota
of Lion King gags today, so Joel,
I wanna stick with you for a minute
with our first topic which is,
are you surprised that the movie is right
at that level of could be
fresh, could be rotten,
because again, this thing comes out,
and even regardless of what
I felt about the movie,
just seeing all the ads for it
and seeing the excitement
that fans had for it,
you would expect this thing to be
up in the 80s or 90s, right?
- I was surprised.
I don't know that I
was expecting the score
to be that high, but the audience
I saw it with certainly
was into this film.
I was tellin' the guys earlier,
the woman next to me was singing along,
fist-pumping, which made my experience
- I'm right here, how dare you.
- somewhat awkward (laughs), exactly.
She's sitting next to me
now, on the Australian couch.
No I think, I was
surprised that it is so low
to be honest, I was expecting
it to be slightly higher.
But we have to understand that this is,
for many people going to see this movie,
particularly people who
do this for a living,
and have to think about the industry a lot
and think about the
state of culture and art,
they're going and seeing this not just
as The Lion King, or The Lion King 2019,
they're seeing this as The Lion King,
the 10th live-action remake from Disney
since Alice in Wonderland.
- Yes.
- And so this film
opens with a huge amount
of baggage because
people are really divided
over what Disney's doing at the moment
with these live-action remakes.
And the whole concept, the whole nature
of this film is divisive
for certain people,
and that discussion is really
bleeding into the reviews
and the takes that people
have with this film.
I'm surprised that it's not
in the 70s or maybe low 80s,
but not overly surprised that there is
something of a backlash coming through.
- Yeah, Maude, I agree with Joel's point
that I think that a lot
of it is just people's
commentary on should we be having
these live-action remakes,
so the score being
as low as it is, is that something
that kinda surprised you?
- Oh, big time!
And I don't really think that it's fair
to a movie, a stand-alone
movie, to own and wear
the baggage of its
predecessors and the decisions
that Disney's making as
a company on the whole.
I think same sort of thing in the cinema
for the world premiere everyone's cheering
and applauding at the end of
every scene, let alone act.
It was such a great atmosphere in there,
I was singing every word,
(all laughing)
which, whatever, but
I absolutely loved it.
And I thought that it looked brilliant,
the story was there,
they kept it authentic
to what the original was whilst
adding new elements to it,
and I thought that that really worked.
Timon and Pumbaa stole the show for me,
I thought that that duo and
that upgrade was fantastic.
It's not a perfect film,
but I absolutely enjoyed it.
- Yeah, Jacqueline, I think that that's
the other question that people have is,
well is this gonna be
as good as the original,
simply because we've seen the original,
and Maude's able to sing with every song.
Maybe it didn't do enough
differently to win critics over,
is that why you see that score so low?
- I have a hard time
with it, and especially
with the critic community
that so often sees
a foreign language entry and
then an English language remake
and can equally like the two of those,
that's the way I kinda looked at this.
I looked at this as, this
is a different language,
meaning the medium of
computer hyperrealistic
photorealistic images,
that is a different medium
to T animations, you're
going to lose things
by going into this next
medium, and you are
gonna gain things by going
into this next medium.
I just think when you
balance the two together,
that's where you kinda
have to basically leave it
where it is, and I do think
this has a ton of upgrades.
I don't know where it sits in the ledger
against the masterpiece
that the first one is,
I don't think it's fair
to compare the two.
However I think there was
a lot of care being placed
in this, Jon Favreau put a lot of respect
to the original and a lot of deference
to the filmmakers and also to Julie Taymor
for what she did in the stage play.
This is not just an adaptation
of the animated classic,
it's also an adaptation of the stage play,
and infusing that in there,
for one is a huge upgrade.
The Nala character's
storyline is a huge upgrade,
regardless of what some of y'all may think
about Beyonce, yes I'm
a Stan, and so as far
as I'm concerned, the
movie is a masterpiece
because it has Beyonce, yes I'll admit it.
However, that doesn't
mean I can't acknowledge
the fact that Beyonce's a great singer,
maybe not the best voice actor,
you know what I'm sayin',
even I can admit that.
- You're really stirring the Hive there.
- I know, the Hive is gonna come for me.
- The comments, direct them
at Jacqueline Coley please.
- I love her, trust me, she's great,
but I do think when you put her
alongside someone like Billy Eichner,
who is a tried-and-true
actor, he does this,
he does voice acting, he
literally does improv.
You can't compare the two,
they're separate roles,
but you can't compare.
- Right, well,
this might be the easiest
spoiler we've ever done
because if you've seen
the original Lion King,
you know what's going
to happen in this movie,
and it's not shot-for-shot,
but it is beat-for-beat.
The big difference, obviously, being
the photorealistic CGI, it's not even
performance or motion capture, I mean,
this is rendered by artists, and I think
that that being the big difference,
Maude, is this live-action
remake, is it taking
enough risks, or do you think
that it's supposed to stay
with the source material
for this particular film?
- I think that this is the
movie where they can do that,
only because it's not
actors having their own
creative input, having their
own creative license with it.
They have absolute control
over how this looks.
I think the problem that
you're finding here is
that the choice to make it
as realistic as possible
whilst trying to retain the
emotions of the characters,
that's where it's falling
short a little bit.
I mean, that beautiful
scene where Simba first eats
the grubs, and it has this (gags) moment,
you're not gonna see a
realistic lion do that
because it cannot physically do that,
it doesn't have that emotion,
and another little gripe
that I have, and I'm so sorry for this,
but if you're gonna make
a realistic-looking lion
cub and hold it up, and
there's no male parts.
- Oh, you wanted to see more, um,
(Joel laughs)
more nudity, I guess.
- But this is the thing where it's like
you're making this
choice, but then you have
to figure out where to draw the line,
ha ha, lion, aah!
- Oh my God.
- Sorry!
- So I would say
that they drew the line
correctly with the holding up
of Simba.
- Yeah I think so,
I missed a lot about this film,
lion peen was not one of those things.
- No, no, you have to take
a moment for lion peen.
- Let's have a (Jacqueline's
laughter drowns him out).
But I actually don't personally feel
like they did take enough risks.
Jacqueline, you mentioned the stage show,
I didn't see the stage show
in this production at all,
and I felt they could've
really drawn from that.
They had a lot of beautiful
music in that stage show,
there's a lot of more
development that happens
in that stage show, and I
don't think it was integrated.
I felt that Favreau, who I
agree did a beautiful job
of directing and putting
together this replica,
I don't think they drew enough,
and I think the Nala storyline, again,
I don't think it was expanded enough,
I think if you look at what they did
with Jasmine in Aladdin,
that felt different to me
from the original characterization.
This Nala, they gave
her a bit more creeping
around the rock with Scar and stuff,
but they didn't take it nearly as far
as they could have taken
it to give us something
that was worth revisiting, I feel.
- You hear the term cash grab
thrown around sometimes too
because everybody knows
if you do this level
of CGI and it looks as
realistic as it did,
I think that it did further
that evolution forward,
but I think that people are going to say,
well it's The Lion
King, of course you knew
you were gonna make boatloads
of money doin' this.
And we've had three
Disney live-action remakes
in the last four months, with Dumbo,
and then Aladdin, and now The Lion King,
so is the term cash grab fair, Jacqueline?
- I mean, yeah, but
so's any movie that goes
to the box office for a certain idea.
They don't put these
out 'cause they love us,
they put them out to make money.
I'm so sorry, if you
didn't guess that by now,
I don't know, maybe you've
missed the whole box office.
- Are you saying it's a business?
- Yeah, it's a business, and so yes,
I think Disney is making
a strategic decision,
however you can still do that with care,
with integrity, you can still do it
with a reverence and a
love for the original.
You can do both, you
can say I'm doing this
to make money, maybe win some awards,
and also because I care and wanna give
this new version to a new audience.
I think you can do both, and
it doesn't necessarily...
Why did we make Endgame,
they wanted it to make money.
So I get why people are angry about it,
I do think they're picking
the wrong properties
to revisit, in my personal opinion.
- Well that's interesting
you bring that up
because those movies that I referenced
that have already come
out, Dumbo and Aladdin,
both, like I mentioned
at the top of the show,
not as well-received as
when Cinderella came out.
Everybody's like, oh
great, because there's
a great graphic that Rotten Tomatoes did
where you see the lineage
of Disney live-action films
as far back as the 1994
Jungle Book, which is fresh.
And then we got a little
rotten for a while,
and then we came back with
the film of The Jungle Book
with all the animals that
Jon Favreau had done,
Cinderella, the Alice in
Wonderlands take it down
a little bit and so it's been
through peaks and valleys,
but Maude it seems like
we're almost going down
another valley at this point.
- Big time, I think
there is such thing as
inundation, and I think
that when you're not even
letting things mellow,
we had the same thing
with Star Wars, I feel,
where that was just trying
to push out as many movies
as possible because it
was making so much money,
by the time we got to
Solo, it was just like,
I'm not even enjoying this ride anymore.
There is too much of a good
thing that can take place.
- That's my defense of Solo,
is it's not a cash grab
because it didn't grab that much cash!
- That's it, they burnt it out,
there was just powder
coming out of the cash cow.
So I think yeah, if we just slow the roll
a little bit, what's the rush,
why do we have to have it all so fast?
And you're exactly right,
there are some stories
that don't need retelling,
and Dumbo is one of them.
Let's talk about the
elephant that was captured
and made to perform for
people's entertainment.
Ah, that was not fun to watch.
- PETA loved that one, but wait a minute,
so your point though about I guess
this whole lineage of the live action
and how many they keep going, for a studio
that has Marvel, that
is literally giving you
the blueprint for how to slow roll
to a grand crescendo,
there are two side studios,
being Lucas Film and Disney proper,
they literally do not follow that formula
- Figure it out, yeah.
- at all,
it's all pedal to the metal, it gives me
a new reverence for Kevin Feige's strategy
and how he's able to maybe push back.
- Well something that Kevin Feige said,
I interviewed him recently
and what was amazing was
that he only thinks in five
and then ten year increments.
So he's not thinking about
how we can get this out
month-to-month, it's like really he thinks
in long-term strategies and
I think that that's so smart.
- Yeah, and I wanna get
into what we're gonna
be seeing from Disney
live-action coming up.
Mulan, we just saw the trailer for that,
that's gonna be a little
bit later in the show,
but for right now, let's move on
to the next topic, and Jacqueline,
I just wanna ask you
about the highs and lows
of this movie, what did you think about,
- The highs and lows.
- what were your
favorite parts, what was maybe not,
more of a meow than a roar for you?
- Actually it's interesting,
one of the highs was
the Timon and Pumbaa
characters, their relationship.
Billy Eichner is definitely
going to break out
from this, I really feel he got to shine
when Seth Rogan talks
about Billy in the movie,
he's like, that's just
him, they captured him.
And what those guys could
do in that booth is really
magical, and I think more people
should pay attention to it.
The lows for me, Be Prepared.
That was a (laughter
drowns her out), huge miss.
- Joel, you are nodding
your head in agreement?
- Yeah, I think it's a beat poet rendition
of a thrilling Broadway song
that doesn't quite land.
I will say on the Be Prepared front,
could you imagine, though, a full version
like the original, 'cause I
think that would just get weird,
with those weird-faced
hyenas sort of singing along?
I don't know that they kind of,
maybe they should have
just snipped it altogether.
- That's the thing, the rumor
was they were gonna cut it,
and in my personal
opinion, they should have,
they should've made a Braveheart speech,
which I think was maybe their idea.
- An anti-Braveheart speech.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah,
or an anti-Braveheart
speech, you know what I mean,
like we're going to do this
and it's terrible, and have--
- We're going to take their freedom!
- Yeah, have that rousing moment,
but don't put it to song.
- Eat some zebras and shit?
- Yeah, yeah, but this is the thing.
Jeremy Irons' entire
character in the '94 Lion King
is camp.
- Yes.
- For all those people at the Met Gala
that didn't understand
the definition of camp,
Jeremy Irons in The Lion King as Scar.
The movie's hyperrealistic
and gritty and dramatic,
camp and realistic are literally
the antithesis of each other, so I get
why they should have cut it out,
and I get why they wanted to.
- Though I think they
achieved some of that
with Timon and Pumbaa.
- Yes!
- Which is interesting 'cause those
two characters were able to go there,
but I think their overall
characterization of Scar
as this darker, more serious character,
wouldn't allow them to
do it, and I would say,
actually, overall
despite Be Prepared being
a bit of a fizzer, Scar himself was a bit
of a highlight for me.
- Yes!
- I felt that Chiwetel did a beautiful job
voicing that character, I
do feel that more than Nala,
the Scar-Sarabi relationship
was actually one
that I liked seeing fleshed
out and felt added a dimension.
Alfre Woodard, also a
high, but you're right,
the only, not the only
reason, but the big reason
to see this film is Timon and Pumbaa
and Billy Eichner, I mean,
he's gay and fabulous meerkat,
- Yeah.
- I can't get enough.
- [Jacqueline] And
Emmy-nominated as of this morning
for Billy (Joel drowns her out).
- [Joel] Yes, congratulations, Billy.
- As soon as Timon and Pumbaa show up,
'cause I love The Lion King, the 1994 one,
but I love it primarily
because of the relationship
with Mufasa and Simba, so that first act
in the 1994 version is what really drew me
to it, Maude, but seeing
this, I would have to agree
that I thought Timon and
Pumbaa were highlights,
but I also thought that the hyenas,
voiced by Keegan-Michael
Key and Eric Andre,
they really made me laugh a lot too.
- I just like that there
was a new take on it.
We could have done
play-by-play, word-for-word,
and they chose not to do that, and I liked
that different take that they had on it.
I think there's a reason why they had
to change one of the hyenas as well.
Which was a good thing,
I'm gonna have to agree
that Chiwetel Ejiofor's
take on Scar was great.
I love Jeremy Irons's version,
but I think it's like,
instead of trying to mimic
or to do exactly the same,
it doesn't work, make
your own version of it,
and some of the characters ran with that,
and some of the characters really faulted
trying to do that, and I
think that Scar was great,
I think it needs to be
camp, and I disagree
with having camp and
realistic don't mesh together.
I think when you look at the live-action
Beauty and the Beast, I
think that when you had
every scene with Luke Evans and Josh Gad,
they went full camp, and
they were the best parts
of that movie, and then
Emma Watson played it
a little bit safe and
didn't go camp at all,
and that juxtaposition
that you had, the synergy
didn't sit there, and
that's what you're having
in this movie, where
Chiwetel's bringing it,
Timon and Pumbaa are going extra camp,
and then you're having
Nala and adult Simba
playing it very realistic and very safe,
and they're not on the same page.
- That's what's interesting to me is
that we're talking about
the highlights right now
and I have not heard
Donald Glover, Beyonce yet
because I felt, I didn't
think that they were bad
by any stretch of the imagination,
but I just felt like I didn't feel
any emotional tinges
with their relationship
or even in their individual
vocal performances.
I thought the performance of
Can You Feel the Love Tonight
played very well, I know
a lot of people were upset
that it was during the day,
but I like the update on it.
It's not gonna do what the
Elton John song does to me,
but I thought it was fine.
- It was getting there,
and then it stopped, I
was like, oh, I'm in this,
and then they went, they
cut out the instruments,
and it sort of crescendoed
and then it just ended,
- She licked his face, and
that's enough for the kids.
- and I was like, oh I
could have done some more.
(Maude drowning out Joel)
- There was chemistry!
- But I'm like, they have chemistry,
I bought Donald Glover a
lot more as this sort of
slacker Simba than I did as the noble
he lives in me kind of
Simba, I definitely liked
that aspect of his performance when he got
with Nala and went back to
save the pride, et cetera,
I was a little bit less enthused.
- I couldn't understand some of his words.
He's like, (mumbling),
I'm like you don't what?
What was that--
- He's got mumble music, so...
- [Joel] You don't need to know the words,
they're the same as the previous
film, every single line.
- Stop, also he's mumble as a rapper,
so I'm not surprised he's
mumble as a voice actor either.
So that doesn't bother
me, but in the original,
the side characters are
just as more interesting.
The side character's always
the most interesting part.
Scar was the most
interesting in the first one,
and so were Timon and Pumbaa,
so they just kept that over.
I'm okay with Nala and Simba
not being as interesting,
'cause let's be honest,
they weren't to begin with.
- There's highs and lows with this movie,
and then there's one
that I'm still confused
in my own head, I'm tryin' to rationalize,
and that would be, the hair
scene where the giraffe eats it
and then we, then the
giraffe, and I'm like,
I'm watchin' the hair blow, and I'm like,
oh great, it's gonna get back to Rafiki
and then he's gonna know, but man,
does that hair take an
interesting off-ramp
through a giraffe's intestinal system!
- It went through the circle of life,
that was the whole point.
- It's the circle of life.
- Very literal, I found
that it was kind of
like a Forrest Gump
feather situation mixed
with just some strangeness for about,
what, 17 minutes or something?
I was like, we get it,
I know what this is.
- But in Forrest Gump,
you never see anybody eat
the feathers then sittin' on the john.
- No, but it coulda been
in those chocolates.
- You're seeing hair
remove itself from dung
and continue to, the dung beetle was cute,
but it's like, I thought
that was interesting.
I'm not ready to say it was bad
or good, but it was interesting.
- This is how it goes,
the animal (mumbles).
- I will say it was the biggest difference
between the films, so I didn't mind that.
- Oh, could I talk about the fact
that Beauty and the Beast
actually got some of their song
in this movie?
- Yes.
- This is the first time
I've ever seen Disney movies
cross-pollinate here,
and I was so about it.
- Shared universe, your
boy Kevin Feige, maybe.
- Except for Pixar, Pixar
always references each other,
but Disney proper, right?
- Yeah!
- But that was also a strange thing
because this is such a
serious, realistic portrayal,
and then suddenly we
have a very Shrek-y kind
of pop culture reference,
which I actually loved,
but again it's like, I
think showed that there were
total inconsistencies
that threw me a little.
- That was from the stage play by the way,
too, since, you know...
- I stand corrected!
- That was from the stage play too,
I don't wanna go down all of the like,
me and Joel later over
some wine, we'll be like,
and this was from the stage play,
and that was from the stage play.
But that was a direct pull,
when I talked to Jon Favreau,
he mentioned that in the stage play,
they reference Frozen, and originally
they referenced Wicked, and
they're referencing things
that are on the stage
near them on Broadway.
And since Frozen is now on Broadway,
they made that in-joke,
like in the live-action,
sorry, in the stage Lion
King they make that joke,
and so he brought over the
Beauty and the Beast one
as his little Disney inside joke.
- So because Jacqueline is
our resident Broadway expert,
did you see anything in this Lion King
that you were like, oh that's definitely,
I recognize that from the stage play,
and I'm happy the did it.
- Yes, first of all,
the Sarabi-Scar thing is directly ripped
from the stage play,
gets more Shakespearean,
gets more Claudius, the
fact that Simba is not
just apathetic but he's more of a slacker.
Not even a slacker, it was he doesn't
have his stuff together in the stage play.
Slacker's probly the
wrong word, that was more
what Donald brought to it,
that's directly from it.
There's a whole bunch of T touches,
I think they pulled
some of the, I would say
regality, to it with the characters,
that's definitely from the stage play,
there's specific parts of Nala's dialog
and specific parts of Scar's dialog
that I remember specifically
from the stage play.
- But there was music
they could have gone with
from the stage play,
- Yes, everyone--
and instead they put the
Beyonce song in, which
- Everyone including myself.
- doesn't work amazingly.
- Everyone including
myself was, what is it,
I see the king in you, I see him in you?
- Yeah.
- I wish that was in there.
- Nala could have had a moment,
which is a beautiful song
that actually fits the
tone of the other music,
whereas the Beyonce song is great,
but I feel as though it's like that thing
where they throw in a new modern song
and it just stands out like a sore thumb.
- Beyonce wants her Oscar,
and that's what she did
the movie for. (laughs)
- Oh, she sang for it.
She trilled her hot ass.
- That's what she wants,
you know that's why they did--
- Does she not have an Oscar yet?
- No, and she--
- Not for Foxy Cleopatra
or something like that, okay.
- How dare you.
- (laughs) I love that film, I love--
(speaking over each other)
- I heard it in Nala.
- I rewatched Austin Powers.
- Yeah?
- I gotta say, yeah, I
would give her an Oscar
in retrospect for that performance alone.
And Maude, we gotta ask you
about the musical selections,
I want you to kick off
this because what was
the highlight musically for you,
and you can (mumbling) if you need to.
- I'm that awful person
that was in the movie
that as soon as the one song was done,
I already was waiting for the next one,
and I knew which one it was, and I knew
how it was gonna get set
up, and it was fantastic
for me, I loved that part of it.
The opening, the very first
shot of this movie was
actually the only one
that wasn't animated.
It was an actual shot of
the sunrise coming up,
so that was beautiful, yep that was great.
Hakuna Matata, Seth Rogan can't even sing
and it doesn't matter, that was so great,
it brought so much heart and soul into it.
Gosh, all of them, no I
even liked Be Prepared.
I thought that it was your toilet break,
sure, but I'm just such a sucker.
- If you woulda called Be Prepared
the drum solo of this
movie, I'm fine with that,
because I will join you in that,
but I also like the
performance of Be Prepared.
Joel, your highlights as
far as musicality goes.
- Music, I thought that
Just Can't Wait to Be King
was done as well as they could have done
Just Can't Wait to Be King, so they set it
around the watering hole,
it's kind of playful,
it's kind of fun, I was with it.
- [Maude] They have all
the baby animals as well!
- Baby animals and stuff,
the opening number,
which everyone's seen in the
trailer, very impressive.
Again, I couldn't get
outta my head with that
because I was like, oh
yeah, and this is the shot
where the bird goes along the lake,
and then this is this one,
and then there's a zebra.
But I couldn't get over it, but I thought
Just Can't Wait to Be King was good,
as I said, Can You Feel the
Love Tonight had its moments.
- Yeah I think it had
its moments for sure,
I'm glad you brought up
Can't Wait to Be King
because I think that
might be my highlight.
Hakuna Matata was so good, and it had
such a showcase to do it,
and I love Billy Eichner
right at the end when he said he's riffing
when he (laughter drowns out words).
Just so much funny stuff in there,
so Jacqueline, the last
word on music goes to you.
- I'm just gonna say them
singing Beauty and the Beast.
That wasn't meant to be
that huge of a musical cue,
but as far as I was concerned,
it gave the best payoff.
So way to go, and that idea, Jon Favreau.
- Well looking forward
to the future of Disney
live action, there's a
lot of question marks now.
Especially, again we go back
to the Tomatometer score,
what does this movie change for you, Joel,
as far as expectations going forward
with the new Mulan movie,
do you think that now Mulan,
obviously it's already in production,
but future live-action
films, I don't think
we're gonna stop getting
them, do you think
that we're gonna see
them stray a little more
from the source material based
on this critical reception?
- I don't know that it's based
on this critical reception,
I think that The Lion King is kind of a,
kind of, is unique in that it's perhaps
the untouchable property,
so there was probably
some trepidation around
veering too far from what is
perhaps the most beloved
of the modern Disney era.
I think these films are
already in production,
and I'm very excited to
see that they do look
like they're going to veer a little bit
from the source materials,
and Niki Caro's Mulan
looks like it's going a
more traditional route,
moving away perhaps there's no music,
perhaps there's no side characters,
I'm all about it, don't get angry at me.
And The Little Mermaid,
not only am I excited
that Rob Marshall I
believe is directing it,
and I thought he did an
amazing job with Mary Poppins,
justice for Mary Poppins Returns,
such a great and underrated film.
But he's directing it and we've got,
it's set in the Caribbean,
- Yes.
- it's very distinctly
set in the Caribbean,
which makes a lot of
sense, and it is gonna be
necessitating a lot of
changes from the original.
So I'm both excited
about those, and I have
no issue with them remaking these films.
The Lion King is a remake
of Hamlet, which has
been done thousands of
times throughout the years.
Aladdin, Disney did not come
up with the Aladdin story.
They have a right to retell these stories,
my hope is that they find reasons for us
to want to go to the theater again
and find something fresh in them.
And some people will find
that in The Lion King,
I didn't find it adequately enough for me.
Keep going, I'm like,
do your worst. (scoffs)
- Do they wanna give us
reason to go to the theater
or do they wanna give us
reason to subscribe to Disney+
because you have Lady and the
Tramp is gonna premiere there,
and I think that's even later this year.
Then you have Sword in the Stone,
which is also in production, Maude.
- Oh that was my childhood right there.
- I love Sword in the Stone.
- (mumbles) oh my God, Merlin!
- Those are gonna be the
more successful properties
because I think Disney needs to go away
from the greatest hits, the
Aladdins, the Lion Kings,
the Little Mermaids, although
I think it'll be great.
They need to get away from these things
that are so beloved and they need to get
into the smaller parts
(Mark drowns her out).
- Go with some B-side.
- Yeah, go with some B-side,
give me some Lady and the
Tramp, which is great,
but can't compare that to The Lion King,
can't compare Sword in the
Stone to Beauty and the Beast.
- I'm also a Sword in the Stone person,
so what is it about Sword
in the Stone that gets you?
- Me, I'm a nerd!
(all chuckling)
Are you kidding me, it's magic!
- And the King Arthur story,
I think it works very well
in animation, obviously with
comedy with Monty Python,
but I think that that is
perfectly sourced for Disney+.
Because to Jacqueline's
point, it may not grab
the wide audience, it would
do well if you released it
in theaters, but I think
that that gets subscribers,
that gets people invested
in a streaming service
which, again, is the
future that we're lookin'
right down the barrel.
- (coughing) Money.
You've got it, you've taken my money, man,
here, Disney, have it all, I'll watch it.
Again, I don't think that
it's fair to blanket anything
when it comes to Disney
properties, I think
that they're harnessing it
in a case-by-case scenario.
With The Lion King it
was nearly the same movie
that we had in 1994, Mulan
and Little Mermaid sound
like it's gonna be very, very different.
Dumbo is a very different
take altogether as well.
So I think that they're going to apply
whatever strategy is going to
work best for that property.
I didn't know about Sword in the Stone,
so that's kinda made my
day, so let me have that.
- Archimedes, how are
they gonna do Archimedes,
I'm very excited.
- What's her name, Meg?
Marvelous with the...
- Oh yeah, the witch, yeah.
- Yeah, that's who I wanna see.
Also, I mean look, we'll see what happens,
but I'm all for Disney+,
plus they're coming out
with a $5 price point for this,
so everyone's gonna sign up for it.
I don't think there's a lot of things
that scare Netflix, but
I would be willing to bet
Disney+ is one of 'em.
- Yeah, for sure.
- Were you excited about the new Mulan,
really quick before we say goodnight?
- 100%.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm down for it.
- All locked into the trailer so far.
- Yeah, it looks great.
- Especially the fact that
Niki's behind the camera.
'Cause I think that's what
they're also gonna do forward,
get filmmakers that have an
identity and an attachment.
- That's the Kevin
Feige thing there, yeah.
- Yes.
- All right, there we go.
Well that's our discussion
about the new Lion King,
the 2019 live-action version
that you can currently
keep track of on
rottentomatoes.com right now.
Whether it stays fresh,
whether it goes back down
to rotten, keep your eyes
on that, and obviously
come see us here at the After Show,
you can subscribe to our
YouTube channel right now
and hit that bell, that's
gonna give you an alert
every time we drop a new After Show.
Love talkin' movies in
full detail with y'all,
thanks to a great panel, and
thank y'all for watchin',
leave your comments below, I'm Mark Ellis,
and we'll see you next time.
(upbeat music)